i i bring up you know trump and the the
resorts
and using them and stuff like that and
i'm critical of it okay but i'm sorry
man
there's more pressing matters than me
getting upset that you know trump put up
some air force men at a golf resort
like the riots in chicago for instance
in june
trump offered up federal assistance and
mayor lori lightfoot of chicago said i
don't need lessons in leadership from
donald trump
we're going to take care of this and
sure enough now about a month and a half
later
chicago lights up with insane looting
and rioting and ransacking
and we have the story check this out
this is crazy so i'm sure most of you
have heard this by now i mean the story
was massive
chicago it's crazy they pulled up the
drawbridges
yep that trapped people inside that's
nice and trapped people outside
so check it out chicago has a uh an area
downtown where the chicago river comes
out of the lake and then creates this
like peninsula where you're at the lake
on one side the river on the other
they pull up all the draw bridges and if
you're downtown you're trapped downtown
if you're north you're trapped north so
imagine you're you're north
you're in the mag mile the looting and
the riding breaks out you panic
so you run south the bridges are up
you're trapped yeah
crazy huh yeah it is there's still
there's still ways you could you could
flee and get out of there
but this was nuts to see in chicago and
one there was an alderman
and he he nailed it okay so if those
unfamiliar aldermen are like local
jurisdiction politicians in chicago
he said where was the plan how did you
not have a plan for this
the the mass looting and writing across
this country just happened a month
before a month and a half ago right
so you had no plan to deal with mass
looting and riding and apparently the
looters had no real reason to do it
they made it up they were just going out
there waiting for that moment
yep yeah so so now the mayor is saying
we are coming for you
she's issued a warning to looters who
ransacked chicago in
uh in a night of straight up criminality
that saw a hundred arrests
and 13 cops injured dude this is nuts
man
they were shooting at cops cops were
shooting back wow
yup it was war man chirac shy rack
and some dude fired multiple bullets
into a gucci window people were
scattering
there's one video where people are
walking and i'll send you here it's like
bang
bang bang bang and people start running
and screaming that's all it was
the funniest thing is there's a video of
a woman looting some kind of mall shop
or something
and she's looking for the thing to
remove uh the security tags yep and then
she yells like i can't breathe i can't
breathe no she's
she's running around trying to find the
keys yeah yeah oh i can't breathe
oh man brutal man yeah it is so you know
look
dang i didn't know look at this right
here shoot out with the police yeah dude
that's nuts yup and uh there's a there's
one video of a cop slumped over
we don't know what happened people wow
yeah they might may be shot we don't
know
getting first aid defend the police 13
13 cops injured
i mean look man i got i got to tell you
it is a crazy world when you get me
defending cpd
i've had agreed i've had a lot of bad
interactions with chicago cops they had
a bad history
but this is beyond beyond the beyond
look i get it man i've actually had some
good interactions with cops i've had a
cop save me from a mugging
but i've had more negative interactions
and positive ones and some pretty bad
bad uh reaction uh interactions but this
is this is nuts
you know i can have beef and be like i'm
annoyed with the police for certain
things
yeah um i'm grateful to the cop who
saved me for that mugging for sure
but this is crazy look at look at this
right here this is some dude
using i think he's driving an audi yeah
and he smashes through the window people
were cheering why'd you do that to your
car
i guess there's i don't know man chicago
like i remember back when the world when
the when the white sox won the world
series
it was crazy dude the riots were nuts
i thought that when the cubs won it was
going to be crazy right it wasn't
but it really wasn't that nuts just walk
down somewhere got smashed up
true that was about it but the parade
was like i think it was like the seventh
or eighth
largest human gathering in history wow
yeah
crazy seven seven million people showed
up these people
so i was talking to my family about this
they got family in chicago yeah and
they're saying that
no one fears the police anymore they
know the cops can't touch them
because it's messed up the viral videos
will spark more riots
and they feel untouchable you got these
these we got tons of photos man it's
it's it it was a it was a wild and crazy
night
and i bring this up specifically because
if
mayor lori lightfoot in june said thank
you mr president i am honored and
humbled by your offer
of federal assistance to deal with our
crime we
are we look forward to working with your
you know your your office
your offices and your law enforcement
officers yeah let us know who we can
contact to organize an appropriate
you know uh enforcement action that
simple professional and calm
and then she could have called and said
here's what we want to do
we want your federal officers to follow
the requests of our local office
you know uh you know local supervisors
who understand the context
just go help that simply need help
that's simple
so right now what's happening is my
understand is what i'm told by people in
the area
the operation legend the fbi agents
they're doing desk duty
and that allows more cops to be on the
ground doing police work
oh okay so trump's not sending people in
to go police the streets
they're just filing paperwork all she
had to say
was i appreciate the offer for
assistance let's coordinate
done and now what do we get after
mass looting and rioting and them you
know they're ransacking stores they're
shooting
at cops cops are getting injured 100
people getting arrested
she looks like man what a dumb mistake
definitely really dumb it's it's here's
what i don't get
if the they hate the president so much
that they would let their cities burn
just to claim they oppose trump that is
a toxic
political political situation agreed
so you've got one political party in
this country that is dedicated
to watching everything around it crumble
it's a kid having a temper tantrum
i'll hold my breath yep so because
you're mad you're gonna hold your breath
you're the one suffering not me
go ahead do it and then the police chief
the
superintendent david brown and and lori
lightfoot went on a pre-press conference
today
and he's talking about you know the cops
the reason they don't have
that they don't have any not the cops
but the people that they're arresting
are just being let out yeah you know the
judges aren't doing anything oh
they're just releasing them all kim foxx
go ahead the d.a
has released 25 000 people that's insane
uh
she's dropped 25 000 uh felony charges
against people
it's a near 35 percent increase from the
previous da
wow so so your point so yeah so he's
sitting here saying that like
the police officers are doing their job
it's not even the police officers
anymore
it's these other it's the rest of the
you know the
system that's just letting them out so
there's no accountability
there's no consequences so no one's
afraid anymore like you were just saying
and so a reporter was basically was like
well it sounds like you're saying that
they're not doing their job
and and the mayor lightfoot walks over
like whoa
whoa whoa whoa excuse me excuse me don't
bait us
don't you bait us into this yeah it's
like that reporter was right
they aren't doing their job they're
letting them out the cops can't even do
their job anymore
the people are are like whatever i can
do whatever i want and you can f off cop
because i can i'm just they're not even
charging us all they're just letting us
go
let me let me tell you about this by
your fault mayor lightfoot
yeah and she gloated in it yeah she
wanted to mock trump
there could have been there could have
been d there could have been atf or
there could have been cbp or ice
and they could have been on the ready
waiting at the command of local cops
local superintendent you know chief of
police saying here's what you guys are
doing they said you got a buddy we'll
help you out trump offered that
assistance they denied it so let me tell
you about trump's america versus biden's
america okay
mayor lori lightfoot hates trump so much
that she's willing to let the city burn
have no plan
and reject trump and insult him for it
okay let me show you something
jake paul yes famous youtuber jake paul
had his home raided
and they did it because the fbi agents
were searching for video evidence of
jake paul's arizona mall looting
incident
when they raided the youtubers calabasas
mansion and emerged with assault rifles
you called it
here's what what i said what what
specifically are you referring to
but i don't want to agree i'm saying
that you called it that they were
looking in his house for footage right
of what
was going on so the feds see a video of
jake paul
in a in a riot and they say we're going
to enforce the law
and they've gone after him they are
going after people like crazy
they're giving um you know they're
they're they're it's legit
yeah what we saw in in the ny with the
nypd
this dude tried cutting nypd break lines
it's alleged oh yeah that's right and so
the
the the local judge released the guy
with no bail so the feds immediately
come
in lock this guy up and now it's being
upgraded i guess the federal charges
probably because the doj is like these
local jurisdictions keep cutting these
people loose that's crazy i mean even
and not only cutting them loose
like in in nypd for example they were
responding to an 11 year old getting
beaten
you know they showed up in on mass to
help
and then a huge group of people started
saying get out of our neighborhood yeah
start
the toss and stuff adam and they had to
they had to retreat so these cops are
getting
their authority stripped for them and
it's going to be lawless land before no
time it's like
these people have no respect for anyone
let alone
police officers you can't do so so
here's what's happening
the reason why i bring up the jake paul
thing it's not just about him
the fbi is investigating which means
that vid that video footage that jake
paul has
it's going to be able to be able to
identify a bunch of other rioters and
looters
now whether or not that's what they're
going for that's what it looks like
they're looking for evidence that's a
good point they're gonna
look this is a guy that's probably got
hd footage of this yep he knows how to
make a video
and now they're gonna be able to look at
all the people who did this and they're
going to let them know we are we are
coming for you
meanwhile in portland night 74 of the
riots last night and what happened cops
got injured burned with mortars
they're marching through people's
residential neighborhoods with bull
horns yelling
you know if we don't no justice no sleep
wait
something like that i thought it was
about the feds being there yep
i thought they were saying that because
the feds were there they were there and
if the feds would leave they would leave
lies yes and now trump has said
the national guard should be deployed
and deployed in portland and i see that
and i'm like well you know what
they had every opportunity to accept
federal help to deal with these they
didn't do it
they're marching through residential
neighborhoods it's only a matter of time
before somebody loses their life over
this definitely they attack someone in
their house
there's a video of them on some dude's
property and he's screaming get off my
property and they ignore him they don't
care
there was that uh that his backpack
viral video of
like i don't know a group of antifa
showing up to some small town
and everyone showed up to get to get
them out and they ended up pummeling
these guys
like oh yeah dude collins fort collins
yeah
and how did tmz frame it oh goodness tmz
said black lives matter protesters like
brutally beaten by pro police
wow yeah something like that that's
ridiculous here's what really happened
antifa tried acting a fool in a fort
collins neighborhood
and so a bunch of locals came out and
said get out of our neighborhood kami
scum
yeah auntie started backing away and
then somebody in the android side
attacked a guy in a wheelchair
so the dudes were like nope and they
wailed on this guy yep
and you know what you attack a guy in a
wheelchair
they're gonna they're gonna defend
themselves they're gonna defend this guy
and so these guys got stomped out
and the cops came in and then the
aunties started fighting with the cops
of course tmz said black lives matter
protesters brutally beaten and it's like
oh dude come on man
now in that video they were very aware
true they were like look look there's
we we have a kid's party over here we
got to lead nt for this way
so they can't get anywhere near the
children you know it's like they were
they were wise they knew what they were
talking about they were clear-headed
these guys were just getting them out of
the neighborhood
and it's like they clearly didn't like
it no
but you know what's interesting that
antifa is going to these areas where
they don't live
it's like they're trying to terrorize
local local residents trying
trying in fort collins they failed okay
good good point
there's we have quite the opposite they
got terrorized that's true
it's not fair to say that though because
the locals were just defending their
neighborhood
but i remember when uh when the riots
broke out
my family in the chicago suburbs were
saying people from outside their
neighborhood were demanding the right to
protest in their towns
and and what we're seeing in portland is
they're screaming things like fire fire
gentrifier
and no justice no sleep yeah so they're
bull horning in people's houses waking
them up
there's one video where they're outside
an apartment yelling we're gonna burn
your building down we know where you
live
they say something like if you have to
wake up in the morning you've been
indoctrinated by capitalism
wow it's it's these people are nuts
that's uh most animals unless you're a
nocturnal hunter
go to sleep when the sun goes down and
wakes up make up when the sun comes up
listen listen it's not for everyone when
when when these people talk about
scarcity being fake and how universal
basic income and all these things i'm
like dude we are not
yet cro across the barrier of post
scarcity
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you